india's healthcare system is contending
with another disease
dengue fever there is an outbreak across
northern india in the capital of delhi
some hospitals are running out of beds
and doctors are turning away patients
sound familiar dw's namisha jaiswal has
more
delhi hospitals are filling up again
this time
with dinghy patients
doctors say complaints of high fever and
body aches spiked in october
over a thousand cases have been reported
in delhi alone
when 15 year old kumar kunal experienced
what he called the worst headache of his
life
his mother traveled over 500 kilometers
from the state of rajasthan to bring him
to this delhi hospital
soon after she was diagnosed with dengue
2.
dengue has spread widely where i'm
coming from and there is a shortage of
beds
serious patients are being referred to
delhi anyway
when i got sick my father decided we
should directly head today
kunal's mother wasn't hospitalized at
first as the limited beds had to be
reserved for more critical patients
it was only when her condition worsened
that she was admitted in a shared space
with her son
she was lucky
doctors here say 9 of 10 dengue patients
have had to be turned away
cases of dengue have shot up across
north india
the worst cases report symptoms like
high fever vomiting hemorrhaging and
organ failure
dinghy can be fatal
there is no known cure
india has struggled with dengue almost
every year after the monsoons
still bodies of water provide ample
breeding grounds for mosquitoes that
carry the disease
after dealing with india's massive
second wave of coronavirus cases earlier
this year
major hospitals are now scrambling to
accommodate dengue patients there was
some bad which were kept for uh kobe no
since kobe patients are low we kept that
also for dengue we created another flu
ward also which also now being used for
dengue fission and many more people who
are waiting for admission and these are
all who are with the complication
the delhi government has now ramped up
fogging drives across the city
it has also called on people to
regularly check for mosquito breeding
grounds around their homes
but some doctors say these measures
should be in place all year to stop
recurring outbreaks
coming at this late stage
these efforts may be too little too late
joining us from delhi is ramel tiku of
max healthcare welcome to the program
thank you thank you so much for having
me
how worried are healthcare workers about
the rise in dengue cases and the ability
of the medical system to potentially
deal with yet another spike in covet
cases
would india i wonder be able to handle
both
i think we're well prepared in case the
numbers go up and post the festive
season we've always seen that the
numbers do go up but we're doing well at
the moment india's had less than 20 000
cases for more than a month now
and even the mortality is pretty low so
we are pretty sure that we'll be able to
handle it but this is sort of a double
whammy where we've had an increase in
the number of dengue cases as well
especially in north india the up and
delhi ups had uh an outbreak in the last
two months where a lot of patients got
infected with the deadly dengue two
strain inferozabah then there was
mortality also especially in children
but things are much better now and uh
we're ramping up the testing the
infrastructure and everyone who needs
hospitalization or medical attention is
being taken care of but having said that
the coming few weeks are very important
because one because of the festive
season the numbers of kovit also might
go up plus the dengue is always there
but hopefully with the temperatures
dipping in
and we will have some respite for from
dengue hopefully in the next two weeks
but till then we have to be on guard we
don't have to get complacent because
we've seen what this can virus these
viruses can do
and of course you mentioned the testing
um our report reminded us that some of
the symptoms of dengue overlap with
covid fever and aches and that will mean
testing are there enough testing kits
out there
yeah there are enough testing kits
available we've ramped up the
testing as i told you earlier in even
the infrastructure is being ramped up
there is an overlap of symptoms because
it's an influenza like illness whether
it's covered whether it's dengue but the
clue is in testing if you test initially
in the first two days there's a dengue
ns1 antigen test it comes positive so
you can take adequate precautions you
have to stay hydrated you have to keep a
track of your complete
blood counts and platelet counts as well
so one has to be very versatile and one
has to be proactive if you have fever in
the first few days itself you should get
tested for dengue and that's how you
differentiate it from uh kovid
ramel tiku thank you so much for joining
us
thank you thank you so much